Happy Birthday, communism.
This year marks 100 years
since communism began.
The First Revolution was in Russia.
No longer would capitalists
exploit workers.
Now the people would
prosper together under Lenin.
But some people resisted,
so Lenin ordered them killed.
“You need to hang without fail",
he said so
the public sees…
the death of the rich,
the bloodsuckers.”
Stalin continued the killing.
MILLIONS of people starved because
it turned out that when
farmers can’t control their property,
they don’t produce much food.
Yet today, many leftist
Antifa activists
carry communist flags.
Some say,
well Russia just didn’t do communism right.
But when has ANYONE
done it right?
The Chinese said
THEY would make Communism work.
Instead a mob of teenagers
called the “Red Guard”
lined up skeptics
and executed them.
Millions were murdered.
Yet even after years of murder,
many Chinese people
still believe.
Look at these people.
They are crying.
Not because they're unhappy,
they're crying with joy and excitement just
because they got to see their leader,
Chairman Mao.
But Chinese Communism failed
even the people who worshipped it.
Lily Tang was a little girl then.
She loved Mao.
But about eight years later…
Lily came to America with nothing.
But here, she thrived…
and last year,
she ran for US Senate
as a Libertarian.
She polled high enough
to make the debates.
Her message was
that life is terrible WITHOUT freedom.
Before she became a Libertarian,
she became a Republican.
But then:
I’ve abandoned free market principles
to save the free market system.
When Colorado debated gun control,
she posted this picture on Facebook
with the caption,
“I once was a slave
I will never be one again.”
She told Colorado’s legislature,
the history of China might have been different
had the Chinese had a right to bear arms.
Now she speaks at colleges.
She says many young people
haven't learned the lessons of Communism.
So I hope more students listen to
Lily Tang Williams.